à l'échelle Vitali sont encore
traumatisés alors qu'il prenait des
photos des véhicules militaires russes
ces habitants de la région de Herson ont
été arrêtés par les occupants ils ont
subi des actes de torture pendant 10
jours
nous avons été attachés et amené à
personne il y avait 12 autres personnes
dont certaines étaient là depuis un mois
il nous envoyait des chocs électriques
parfois il nous menaçait avec des
pistolets
ils ont même menacé de nous faire
marcher sur un champ de mine
autour de mes reins ici ils m'ont frappé
ils m'ont donné des coups de poing sur
le visage jusqu'à ce que mon essaigne un
régime de terreur dont personne porte
encore les stigmates une semaine après
sa libération par l'armée ukrainienne ce
centre de détention fait partie des 11
recensés par les autorités dans les
environs la violence y était quotidienne
j'ai vu des gens fait prisonniers les
yeux bandés ou avec un sac sur la tête
il les retenait ici et les interroger
tout le monde essayait d'en durer cela
du mieux possible et de se cacher
les forces de l'ordre ukrainienne disent
avoir mises au jour plus de 434 de
crimes de guerre dans la région un
chiffre jamais vu dans le pays depuis le
début du conflit
la politique